in the weird world of nfts there is
something sinners are going on where
criminals are making off with millions
with what's called a rug pull
you simply build a following of
degenerates that are hungry for a quick
buck you create an nft project you build
insane hype by promising them the world
and then when your project sells out
then comes the rug pull you delete
everything disappear and voila you just
made off with millions of dollars in the
span of just a few weeks
yeah so a rug pull is a very common term
i mean the metaphor is that you get all
these people all excited they're on a
rug and you pull it out from under them
right and so essentially what we see
with a lot of these scam projects
essentially is that they make all the
promises in the world tell them this is
the next best nft they use a lot of
predatory marketing tactics just to get
everyone to buy their project and once
everyone buys the nfts the project sells
out they just delete the discord and
goes how many millions can you make off
of a single rug poll well if an nft
project has 10 000 copies and each of
them sells at 350 a piece that is 3.5
million dollars for selling jpegs and
it's pretty much all profit by the way
yeah so it's not uncommon to see a three
million dollar mint and when i say like
that that means all profit like there
are not a lot of expenses this is brett
malinowski he's built and sold out 12
nft projects he's got one of the biggest
nft youtube channels out there and since
he advises nft projects he has to shift
through a ton of bad projects every day
so he knows all the tricks these
predators use
but that's not even the best part see
traditionally if you wanted to scan
people in the real world you would have
to show your face in one way or another
but in the nft world it's all anonymous
there's no sec but even more than that
is that being anonymous is part of the
culture of crypto and because of this
you can rinse and repeat the rug pull
over and over and over again up to two
rug pulls a month that's around six
million dollars and practically all
profit in a month or 72 million dollars
a year and you just rinse and repeat but
you have to make a new anonymous thing
that's the hard part is you're gonna
have to build up your reputation again
but if you have all these like tools in
your pipeline you can get get it down to
a science pretty if you don't have
ethics like
and you can say whatever you want and
you're just marketing taking advantage
of people's psychology
uh yeah it's pretty easy to continue to
do over and over again and we see it
happening right now it's a huge problem
it's kind of ingrained in the culture of
cryptocurrency and bitcoin to be
anonymous like it's a decentralized open
world where everyone is treated fairly
and equally and so it's pretty accepted
in our culture to be anonymous that's
the hype around these nfts that you can
use it as your profile picture and that
is like your your identity online but
since they're anonymous there's no
repercussions they can just rinse and
repeat get a different profile picture
change the name use the same tactics as
a new batch of people and over and over
again and here's a simple tutorial on
how to do a rug pull yourself let's talk
about rug pulls so let's pretend me and
you were going to start a rogue pull
like how do we go about this step by
step
like step one step two step three i
don't know if we should be equipping
people with this power but
step number one create your persona what
is the fastest way to gain credibility
in the nft world buying a valuable nft
to use as your profile picture pretty
much everything in the nft space happens
on twitter or discord so that's where
you're going to create your online
persona you want to look like you have
money like you know what you're doing
and the best way to do that is to buy a
really well known nft art piece use it
as your profile picture on twitter and
discord and boom
people instantly think this guy has
money so he must know what he's talking
about now sure it may cost you a good
chunk of ethereum to get a board ape
yacht club but trust me the investment
will be worth it think of it like
getting a lambo to take a picture with
to use as your profile picture except in
this case it's even better because you
don't even have to show your face it's
like a part of the culture and it's like
the norm almost like almost everyone is
anonymous and that's really what
attracts a lot of people to the space
because they can really be whoever they
want but of course people can just get
away with stuff like this so if you
could get an nft from like one of these
really notable sets like the board yacht
club crypto punk you're going to like
instantly get credibility in the space
like that
how do people verify that you actually
own it well now before like a week ago
it wasn't possible they could see your
wallet but who's how do you know that's
someone's wallet when they're anonymous
but now on twitter you can at least
verify that you own an nft if you own
that twitter account you're the only one
that can prove that you own that wallet
oh no way yeah so you can verify that
you own nfts on twitter now so step one
is if you're going to build it around
your personal anonymous brand just get a
really high like high status nft making
your profile picture on twitter people
are instantly going to think you're
credible because they know you have a
lot of money now that you have a
credible profile picture nft it's time
to build up a personal brand now when
you hear the word personal brand you may
think you'll need millions of followers
before you can do a rug poll but that
couldn't be further from the truth see
the nft community is still super small a
lot of the time the big names in the
space only have a couple thousand
followers but what is important is that
the followers you do get are real and
hungry for money after all fake
followers aren't going to buy your nft
get active in the nft community on
twitter join other nft discords build
your credibility and then you want to
drum up some curiosity let us look that
you're launching a big project soon and
then it's time to move on to step number
two
now step number two is really see what's
working right now see other hyped up
projects that are coming out that people
are really excited about and make art
that's very similar to theirs okay in
the nft world there's always legitimate
projects that are taking off and going
viral they are trending and once people
start seeing the price of a trending
project go to the moon they're gonna
want to get in on that but it would be
too late they miss the train so they'll
start looking for similar projects to
buy hoping that it will go up so all you
gotta do is look at whatever projects
are going viral at the moment and create
art that looks very similar to that one
yeah so step number two was
you know choose looking at what's being
hyped right now the projects and then
making similar art to that so can you go
into that a little bit more yeah so of
course there's plenty of different ways
we've seen huge rug pulls that had
completely unique art and made big
promises but really it's the quickest
way is to capitalize on hype from other
projects so right now we're seeing a big
project called the invisible friends
which is a great project great team very
transparent fantastic art but they have
hundreds of thousands of followers on
twitter so what we see is what we call
the meta in the nft space and right now
the meta was started by them are these
walking nfts so we're seeing a lot of
these rug pull projects make a trailer
that makes their entities look like
they're walking and then they'll get 50
000 100 000 followers because people
like oh my god this is the next
invisible friends but in reality come
mint day the actual nft isn't walking
they just made a hype trailer that
looked like that to capitalize on live
interesting interesting to actually make
the art all you have to do is hire some
cheap designer promise them a small
percentage of every nft sold and tell
them to make something similar to the
project you're trying to copy now a
project copying the style of another
doesn't automatically mean it's a red
pole but when you combine this with
other factors we're about to talk about
the chances go up
now that you have the foundation in
place for a successful rug pull it's
time to build up as much hype as
possible before your launch day the day
that your project goes live and people
can pay three four five hundred dollars
to buy or mint your nfts on your website
step three promise the world say this is
going to be community you want everyone
to be friends you want you're going to
give them so much value they're going to
make passive income the underlying
message behind all your hype should be
you're going to get rich buying this nft
i would say that's the main incentive
why most people in the nft space are
participating in trading and flipping
nfts because there's so much opportunity
for that and that's really been kicked
off by the board api club which is by
far the biggest nft project right now
the floor of the board api club is over
115 eth right now and one ethereum is
like 2700 so it's almost 300 000 for a
picture of a monkey and so everyone is
looking for the next sport api club
hopefully they can flip up and make some
more money so that's definitely a heavy
incentive right now and so people
predatory projects like this lean into
that and make all these promises that
you're going to make a lot of money this
is the next board api club and they'll
use that type of messaging in their
marketing and so the new person doesn't
know too much and they just like
instantly think they found the next
board api club don't do any research buy
in and all of a sudden the project's
dead one great way to get people excited
about your projects is to simply copy
and paste another big project's roadmap
a roadmap is how a project plans to keep
the price skyrocketing after they launch
and every project lists their roadmap on
their website real nft projects put a
lot of thought into their roadmaps and
actually plan on fulfilling those
promises you don't have such a burden so
just copy and paste a great enticing
roadmap from another project offer the
same perks tease the same feature
developments like ethereum giveaway
selling merch or developing games based
on the nfts or that you're gonna launch
your own token or that you're gonna
launch your own dow or that holders will
receive passive income somehow in other
words make it seem like this is the next
nft project that's going to blow up so
you better get in on the launch before
they sell out and on top of that more
people are going to want to join the
community that costs the average price
of the nft to go up and so if you're an
early supporter you got in at the lowest
price you minted the project if the team
does what they promised project floor
goes up everybody makes money
everybody's happy now you just have to
spread the word get influencers to post
about your entities on their socials
engage with your audience make it seem
like you're the most sincere nft project
founder in history all you want to do is
build an amazing community all with the
goal of getting as many people into the
discord as possible then you want to
lock in buyers with what's called a
whitelist
okay so now you have all these people
excited about your project you have a
lot of followers typically we have what
we call discord and that's where the
community lives so now this is where you
take it and get the hype on steroids
basically there's these things called
whitelist spots meaning that you're
guaranteed the mint because 50 000
people want one of these there's only 10
000 of them yeah not everyone can get
one so they give away these whitelist
spots and with these whitelist spots
they actually say you have to invite 10
friends into the discord with all the
hype in place now is the time for the
moment you've all been waiting for the
road pole
it is finally launch day and with the
click of a button your nft project goes
live and if you did your job right
people will flood in it sells out and
you have a few million dollars in your
pocket within the span of a few hours
and then it's time to pull the rug
lead up the mint have people do
giveaways make them invite people to the
discord to get perks to get on the white
list and then on the mint day you sell
out and once you sell out
ghosts delete the discord you're nowhere
to be found delete your twitter account
new account
now when you pull the rug is up to you
you can do it right away and troll them
or you can let it ride for a little
while
some people can just act like they're
working behind the scenes and put on a
show for like a month and be like yeah
so much coming big announcement next
week and that's gonna bump their floor
price and then they get royalties from
that or you'll see the people who
literally don't care at all and they're
just doing this every two weeks just
delete the discord and almost like in a
sick way like troll people and just be
like get rugged delete the discord
delete the twitter and don't even care
like they almost like find joy in it so
yeah there's total different ways to do
it but grand scheme yeah typically we
see people just delete their discord
delete their account
do it all again and congratulations you
just pulled off your very first rug pull
but why stop there it's time to rinse
and repeats
okay how often can they repeat this
process like how quickly so
honestly i bet if you were like
efficient you have a whole team you're
committed and your morals are out the
window probably at least one every two
weeks one every two weeks if you're good
okay now if you have a conscience and
don't want to screw people over there is
still plenty of money to be made off of
the hype of projects that aren't rug
pulls the trick is being able to tell
them aparts
how can you easily tell the rug pulls
because you've analyzed a ton of
projects
and you talk to like founders of
projects all the time how can you tell
the rug pulls apart from the real ones
yeah so this is something that's very
hard for new people but since i've been
in the space for so long i've seen so
many of them so many different projects
i've been able to pick up on them quite
quite quickly and basically is like not
one of these alone says that's a rug
pull but if you start to see a lot of
compounding of these tactics you're
going to start getting a lot of red
flags start questioning so if you see
like non-original art like they kind of
copied a different project's art style
and then you see a copy paste roadmap
meaning a roadmap that worked like for
other projects recently last week so
it's just a like just a combination of a
lot of copying and pasting because
they're trying to do it in two weeks
they're not trying to think for
themselves
and so if you see a project that doesn't
really have any new idea no new road map
no new art style
not necessarily bad
but there's a good chance that they
probably don't have the best intentions
because they're not thinking for
themselves and on top of that look at
the communication of the discord how are
the founders talking are they hopping on
like q and a's are they engaging with
the community if not
they don't seem as genuine they're
actually not there to foster community
they're there to take advantage of you
now this has been a pretty pessimistic
view on nfts which sucks because i do
genuinely think there's a lot of
potential for them for example one way
i'm planning on using nfts myself in the
future is selling an nft as a login to
software or digital content that way at
least you have the chance of reselling
it versus just losing your money i built
the match mushroom clubhouse that's my
pride and joy and then i've been an
advisor and helped build other projects
over i think 12 now and all of which
have sold out in a very timely manner so
i've got some experience in my belt on
top of that before that i was flipping
nfts this summer and so safe to say nfts
have absolutely changed my life but i
just think this technology is super
powerful and this is absolutely the
future so i've committed my whole life
to this so obviously there's a lot of
bad stuff that happens in nft space you
said you were dedicated to this for your
entire life like what do you see in the
space that you know keeps you going and
stuff yeah so right now what's going on
is silly and if you try to explain it to
someone it doesn't really make sense
like why are these pictures trading for
hundreds of thousands of dollars and i
would agree like it doesn't make sense
but this technology all it is nft
technology it means it's a non-fungible
token aka like a token id that can't be
replicated it's completely unique which
means it's just a better way to verify
that somebody owns something aka it
makes the internet ownable like you can
prove that you own a digital item that
idea is extremely powerful but we're so
early and so new that the best way we
are utilizing that is saying that you
could own a picture of an animal
so it's very very very early and so once
we actually
develop this i see car titles house
deeds all of these things that you need
to verify that you're the owner of will
be nfts because on an immutable
blockchain that can never be edited
never be hacked if you own something on
the blockchain it's there forever and
everyone in the world can see that
you're the owner uh do you recommend
people getting into the nft space right
now
this okay so if you look at the first
off i'll start like this yeah this is
the biggest opportunity for one of what
i think is going to be the biggest
market of all time ever this is the
biggest thing since this is the biggest
innovation since the internet and if we
look at a trend line comparing internet
adoption to blockchain adoption
we are in 1998 and it follows the trend
exactly so on a macro level we are
seeing the exact same adoption rate and
so fundamentally this technology will
change our world it will eliminate
friction and it's just a better way to
do things and a better way to verify who
owns what and so
why would you not want to commit to this
field that's going to be around and
impact and change our world for years to
come so how do you recommend people
getting into this yeah so flipping and
trading nfts is how most people hear
about it because there's a lot of money
and that's what catches most people's
eyes now that guys you have to
understand that's like a can it's very
akin to gambling essentially you're just
gambling because you don't know which
project's going to go up no matter what
influencer says we really can't predict
the future obviously and so that's a
good way to learn and have a financial
incentive in the short term but if you
really educate yourself and understand
why this technology is so powerful and
really try to start to understand it
there are so many holes in the market
pretty much every business that we see
in the world all these fortune 500
companies could very well use an nft
strategy in their business to make their
business better more profitable and more
consumer friendly and so
that's going to be a time like we're
already seeing it big companies nike
adidas budweiser burger king all these
pro companies are getting into the nft
space and they're the pioneers they're
the first ones and so right now if you
wanted to start your own business
there's no better business to start than
a nft strategy like advising company for
fortune 500 companies like pretty much
any business that's running in the web
2.0 world
is needed in the web 3 world so whether
you have a completely new business idea
or you just want to make like the quick
books of nfts we need that right now and
so there's so much space if you can just
get in now start building you're going
to be so much further ahead of these
companies that haven't figured this out
yet kind of like the route you took
where you started trading first you made
like a decent amount of money and then
you move on to more of like creating and
building projects is that correct yeah
100 so i did pretty well flipping nfts a
nice six figures from not that much of
an investment okay
obviously at some risk i got lucky along
the way some places but once you realize
like i'm making a lot of money flipping
nfts you realize oh my god
the project that i'm buying these nfts
from are making five percent of every
single transaction so like that's where
the real money is at on top of that i
had a good understanding for the space
we had a lot of information we thought
would help a lot of people so that's why
we made our project the matching
mushroom clubhouse and since then i've
really got a deep understanding of this
technology we've just found more and
more ways to help more and more people
so if people want to get into flipping
like you said to start out are there any
projects that you're looking into right
now that you see potential in yeah and
one thing i want to make clear when
you're new you need to spend a little
more time to really try to understand
that this team is authentic they care
they actually want to build something
because it's really hard to
differentiate who is using these
buzzwords to manipulate you and who
actually has good intentions and wants
to build something for the long run and
so i guess i'll use the project that
we're advising for is the example the
cunning wolf society these are two guys
that have exceptional backgrounds
they're both ai developers they hop on
question and answers amas and their
discord talk to their community all the
time they're super active on twitter and
they're always coming up with new
creative like story lines for their
project and so they're trying to create
a basically an nft data tool for all
their holders to use to become more
effective and efficient traders and if
you own their nft you get access to that
tool for free and so what i'm looking
for and why they checked all the boxes
for me is of course they had great art
that's the thumbnail that's what catches
people's attention on top of that they
had founders that were competent they're
ai developers they talk to their
community on a regular basis like with
their voice they you can look them up on
linkedin you know who these people are
on top of that they're doing everything
right when it comes to actually rolling
out and not doing these like predatory
tactics where you have to you know
invite 10 people to discord just to
possibly buy can you explain more what
the dad tool is
yeah so i'm a big data guy when you're
in the nft space you'll see like these
projects pop off out of nowhere and
their floor price goes up 20 30 in like
an hour and you have you have to
understand why and so when you have
these data tools you can kind of see
who's buying these you can see how like
if there's whales like people have a lot
of money are they buying this or is it
the general public on top of that which
ones are they buying so you get like a
much more you can kind of paint the
picture for you for why this project's
doing so well and what caused it if that
makes sense so there's like uh like
intrinsic value in the project exactly
it's like a value back to nft basically
there's like
real value backed behind this nft you
actually get something with it and their
competitors cost over 150 a month
starting and that's not reasonable for a
lot of people and so they want to create
an nft where you can access this tool
completely for free which i think is a
very innovative way and then if you
don't like the tool you just sell the
nft and get your investment right back
so it's really important when you're
flipping and trading nfts to really just
give yourself an edge and these data
tools really just stack the deck in your
favor because you have access to all of
the information out there as quickly as
possible and you're getting alerts so if
you guys were interested and you
actually do want to check out this
project and actually get access to this
data tool it's called cunning wool
society and they're minting on january
6th we're both advisors for them so they
have our co-sign and honestly i think
they're one of the biggest upcoming
projects right now awesome sweet i'll
link to the project brett mentioned
below and again full disclosure me and
brett are advisors for the projects
[Music]
you